next on american history tv nate jones
director of the national security
archives freedom of information act
project talks about his new book able
archer 83 the secret history of the nato
exercise that almost triggered nuclear
war
mr jones explores ronald reagan's
thoughts on nuclear policy during the
early 1980s and details the war game
that the soviets nearly mistook for the
beginning of an actual surprise nato
missile attack
jones also discusses the process of
declassifying the government materials
that were the basis of his book this
hour-long event is hosted by the
national archives in washington d.c
it's said that in washington the first
place people look in the newly published
book is the index to see if they're
mentioned
here at the national archives i'd like
you to say
at the library of congress and other
research institutions we look at
acknowledgements pages and the
bibliography also
looking for ourselves
if you look at the acknowledgments of
able archer you'll see that nate jones
has noted the assistance of several
national archives staff members at the
presidential libraries and and the
information security oversight office
known as isu
a large portion of the documents upon
which he based his story came from the
ronald reagan and george bush
presidential libraries and from the
national archives
other national archives holdings
i'm very proud of our staff some of whom
are in the audience today
and it's gratifying to see that others
appreciate the work they do whether it's
helping people navigate through our
holdings or as nate noted breaking a
declassification log jam to release a
critical document
every day in research rooms across the
country we help researchers uncover the
stories of our past
and those stories like today's story of
abel archer remind us that history is
not just what happened a hundred or more
years ago as more and more records are
processed and declassified we learn more
about the past even events that have
occurred in our own lifetime
now it's time to have our featured
speaker come to the stage
nate is the director of the freedom of
information act project for the national
security archive at george washington
university
he oversees thousands of freedom of
information act and mandatory
declassification review requests and
appeals each year and is a two-term
member of the federal foia advisory
committee
which will be meeting here tomorrow
he's also the editor of the national
security archives blog
unredacted where he writes about newly
declassified documents and foia policy
ladies and gentlemen please welcome nate
jones
[Applause]
thank you very much
it's really great to be here at the
national archives where i spent a lot of
time researching
but also working on freedom of
information and declassification policy
i was here for the first time on this
stage about eight years ago talking
about declassification and nara
and there's a funny story that i'd like
to tell um
nara and the national declassification
center were just ramping up and one of
their first big projects was
uh the declassification of the pentagon
papers which had
topically already been leaked and were
widely available to the public and at
the time i was young it was eight years
ago
i made
the archivist had made the joke that
there were just 11 words
remaining classified and i was a bit
taken aback and i came on the stage and
a bit pompously said well i can solve
that mad lib that's the arc i've joked
i'll just go to my public library get
the gravel edition and compare the
missing words uh they got some laughs
some nara people were not happy um but
eventually uh it may have worked because
through foia an archivist uh at the
nixon library um
these emails were released via foia very
quickly so more credit to them
said in an email to his superiors
well we found that there is in fact
another edition their gravel edition
didn't have them it was actually the
armed services committee edition did has
these words that we've redacted so we
should probably release them before
someone at the for at the national
security archive goes around and parades
them like a politician on the 4th of
july
so that was my first experience and the
national archives and the national
classification center declassified the
pentagon papers officially and then they
went on and on and on and declassified
millions and hundreds of more millions
of pages and keep doing it
and i must say i'll talk a little bit
about classification later on but
they're
indexing on demand program at the
national declassification center should
be a model for all agencies
declassification and foia it's great and
tremendous progress over the past eight
years
getting the secrets out
so
uh with that thank you uh let's talk
about able archer 83
so what
was able archer 83
according to
the nsa's history not the national
security archive wirework the real nsa
they have an excellent four volume
history of the cold war that's one of
the best declassified reads
i've read
they called the years
1982 to 1984
quote the most dangerous confrontation
since the cubone missile crisis able
archer 83
held in november 1983 was the crux of
this was a nato nuclear
release exercise that caused an
unprecedented nuclear reaction from the
soviets according to british
intelligence and may have put our
nuclear relations with the soviet union
on a hair trigger according to a u.s
analysis of the incident
in other words one of the two most
dangerous moments of the cold war
is largely unknown to the public
in my book i argue that able archer 83
brought the world unacceptably closer to
nuclear war that it had a key effect on
our foreign policy
and its effect
on its danger
helped reagan decide and lead to the end
of the cold war
speaking of president reagan here's one
of his famous um
note cards every you may know that he
always went in the meetings with note
cards
prepared by his staff but he used them
and used them well this is a great
document from the reagan presidential
library um
and uh
going back to abel archer 83 others uh
have downplayed the danger or said that
it's simply not even worth studying
one cia analyst wrote at the time
that there was no real danger and uh
wrote afterwards
that the cia's analyst of analysis of
the war scare was that since the agency
had so many soviet military cookbooks
they could judge confidently the
difference between when they might be
brewing up for real military
confrontation or just rattling pots and
pans
the response to able archer 83 the cia
concluded was that it was just pot
rattling
but another
wise cia analyst that will be here
tomorrow night disagreed
robert gates
who
was a deputy director for intelligence
during the war's gear wrote
after going through the experience at
the time
then through the post-mortems and now
through the documents
i don't think the soviets were crying
wolf
they may not have believed a nato attack
was imminent in november 1983 but they
did seem to believe that the situation
was very dangerous
rattling pots and pans crying wolf or as
reagan asked his advisor to the soviet
union in early 1984
do you think the soviet leaders really
fear us or is all the huffing and
puffing just part of their propaganda
that
president reagan identified was the key
question and i think he answered it for
himself later on which i'll talk about
later but as i studied this 1993 warsaw
enable archer and as we talk about today
i think this is what we need to keep in
mind were the soviets really scared or
were they bluffing
so to answer this question
what is a historian to do
um well
when i first started researching this
there is quite a bit of criticism even
about able archer 83.
some described the research as
an echo chamber of inadequate research
and misguided analysis
and circle reference dependency with an
over reliance upon the same scanty
evidence
now i think they were talking about some
of my early work which is fine
and also they had a good point if you
were to read a history one of the best
and best history of the cold war and go
to abel archer uh you would see a note
that said marked the second most
dangerous point of the cuban missile
crisis but if you followed the footnotes
it would go to one or two memoirs or
perhaps that gates quote that i just
read and leave it at that no primary
source evidence
so what's a historian to do
get to the archives get to the
presidential libraries
get to the cold war international
history project get documents from our
nato allies and adversaries out use the
freedom information act
use mandatory declassification review
turn to ice cap get them to break the
log jam we'll talk about how they did
that later maybe
and then share the filings of the new
earth documents so this is what my book
tries to do it's the narrative and
analysis of able archer 83 but it also
includes the very best primary sources
for people to read so they can make
their own
decision and conclusions about the
danger
so
let's set the scene
here
we have the data from the bulletin of
atomic scientists put together kindly by
wikipedia about the doomsday clock which
uh
is a estimation of
how dangerous the world is coming to
nuclear war or now environmental
catastrophe and as you see there in 1983
and 1984
it was dangerous
some have called this period the second
cold war others have called it the error
of renewed confrontation
mikhail gorbachev have described the
years the most explosive difficult and
unfavorable since the second world war
so i won't spend too long running back
to running through how we got there but
i will say that it was geopolitical
um
and
geopolitical ideological uh on the one
hand but also nuclear on the other and
that's key um
geopolitically there was of course the
soviet invasion in 1979 that essentially
ended the taunt
carter's focus president carter's focus
on soviet human rights abuses
the united states tilled towards china
and then this was manifested in
boycotting of olympics in both 1980 and
moscow in 84 in la
but as important as the ideological and
geopolitical reasons for this souring of
relations
was the nuclear
reasons
and this started with the soviet's
decision to deploy new ss-20 missiles on
their western border which could reach
europe and escalated the arms race
later on they admitted in as much in
politburo meetings saying this was a
mistake my colleague my tom blanton has
published a great book including these
minutes um but they the soviets began
the euro missile race
then nato responded 1978 deciding to
deploy pershing missile pushing two
missiles and griffin missiles into
europe
which were deployed in late november
1983 days after able archer 83 had ended
this was extremely unbalancing to
the relative geopolitical and nuclear
stability um the reason for this was
that now uh the soviets believed that
the pershings could reach moscow within
15 minutes they probably couldn't
but the u.s wasn't telling the soviets
that the pershings could reach russia
and
forward deployed soviet troops
within less than 15 minutes the griffins
could reach moscow in under an hour and
also the griffins in all likelihood
could not be detected by radar so
essentially
the euro missiles on both sides but
especially the pershings and the
griffins
change the balance so that now the
soviets were genuinely fearful of the
possibility that they could uh be hit by
a decapitating nuclear attack that is
all of the work they had done to build
up nuclear parity and stay just behind
the united states in the arms race had
been obliterated or would be obliterated
when the intermediate ranged missiles
were deployed to europe
this fear
of the decapitating strike that was the
primary driver of able archer 83. it
also drove a change to
uh on both sides of the consideration
and possible application of a strategy
known as launch on warning
now today in the united states uh in
the american nuclear posture review
which is unclassified available on the
web our current posture is launched
under attack and this is scary to talk
about and surreal to talk about but
these are the facts
right now our posture is is that if an
adversary launches nuclear weapons at us
when they're in the air we will launch
ours to retaliate
in
1983 with the intermediate-range
missiles and
response time of just minutes both sides
contin considered using and may have
used launch on warning that is
use good intelligence
to figure out when your opponent is
going to launch an attack at you and
then preempt your opponent so that you
can
maybe possibly survive and possibly even
win the war
with low gains and there's many
interviews cited i said in the book with
soviet american scientists after the
cold wars and um
morosely joking with each other that if
you if you say that you didn't study
that you're lying and the other side
agreed um so lots of warning is another
key driver of abel archer 83.
i'm talking a lot about
u.s
nuclear drills today but but there's one
other famous one that i want to briefly
mention called zapad 83 which the soviet
union practiced in 83 and according to a
member of the general staff
this was the first time since the world
war ii the soviets actually practiced
the drill of obtaining information
stating that the adversary was going to
attack and then the soviets practiced
this preemptive strike including a
preemptive nuclear strike so
this was
on the minds and being practiced
this leads me to what i'd like to
discuss uh something called operation
rihanne um operation rion sometimes in
the west called operation ryan but um
it's a russian acronym uh that stands
for rochetno
uh yadarina napadania nuclear missile
attack in russian and this was um
so this document is one of the rare ones
that gets your heart beating if you see
it it's a kgb document uh that actually
discusses um the creation of operation
rion
and is quote to strengthen our
intelligence work in order to prevent
opposing a possible sudden outbreak of
war by the
enemy um
and what operation rion was was a shift
from
military satellite
and other intelligence towards human
intelligence
with the aim of possibly preempting or
discovering and preempting a nuclear war
it began in 1979 and was announced in
1981
when yurian dropoff who was then the
head of the kgb announced it he said it
was because the west was actively
preparing for nuclear war
the primary accounts of
operation rion until recently was
primarily from
a man named olaf gordiavsky we'll talk
about later but he was a high-ranking
soviet kgb official at one point the
number one official in the london
residency that defected in place
and gave lots of good intelligence to
great britain and eventually the u.s he
eventually for a long time
was the primary source about abel archer
as well
but now thanks to the work of the cold
war international history project there
is a very good web posting of a slew of
hundreds of pages of documents of stasi
intelligence about operation rion so we
know a bit more
what what are some of the things we know
about this new program
um involved over 300 new positions
created in this kgb and even more in all
of its
satellite countries that also spied for
rion
and these positions monitored
indicators that their spies abroad
reported
essentially there was a binder full of
292 indicators that i'll talk about in
one second that spies abroad in addition
to all their other duties had to report
back on some of these were
probably smart like monitoring nuclear
missile sites
monitoring political and military
figures
others were probably far-fetched such as
monitoring blood banks or monetary
priests
the thinking was that if you have enough
data
big data as early as 1981
you can input this data and determine
what is going to happen the soviets also
according to the reports
credible reports invented a rudimentary
computer system to track this data
and what this meant was that the agents
abroad were swamped with more work but
they did not complain they reported
and one of the the top one of the
interesting things they reported
actually applies to where we are today
uh one of the things that agents were
tasked to monitor was the state uh of
the constitution declaration and other
founding documents at the
us national archives the thinking being
that if the imperial west was going to
launch a nuclear strike
they would uh hide their documents first
archivist today told me that that's not
unprecedented and it did happen during
world war ii
these ryan watchers also going through
the documents pretty fascinating two
things that you can kind of tell
one is you can tell where they had good
sources and good agents within the u.s
government because there was much more
reporting these are stasi documents and
the second is that you could tell that
from a pretty early point they did a
pretty good job ferreting out and
reporting on
continuity of government operations
which essentially is the plane that the
president would fly on during the
nuclear war and they also monitored that
ominously
they also include several indicators
that would have been included during
abel archer 83 this nuclear release
exercise that coming up we'll talk about
it's including
mobile troop mobile mobilizations
changes in communications used to launch
nuclear weapons um
and uh new methods of transmitting
weapons
of course rion was searching for
something that did not exist western
plans for a decapitating strike uh
were not in the making possible reasons
for this were bureaucratic expansion
would not be the first time an
intelligence agency created an enemy or
created a greater threat of enemy for
more work for itself um
possibly socialist dogma maybe they
really did believe that some did believe
that
socialism was going to lose to
capitalism and they should go out with a
last gasp
or maybe perhaps even a cockamamie
scheme to inject r d through espionage
because
they weren't soviets were not having
great success making computers otherwise
um
but i think the best uh explanation was
actually coined by gordievsky who first
reported it uh he called operation rion
a vicious circle
of intelligence collection assessment
where soviet intelligence operatives
abroad were required to report alarming
information to moscow about a western
surprise strike even if they themselves
were skeptical of it
after the moscow center received these
inflated and incorrect but requested
reports the western preparations for a
surprise nuclear strike it became duly
alarmed by what had been reported and
demanded more
the day after anybody remember this
um so shifting from a secret fear of
nuclear war to very public fear of
nuclear war
the 1980s i'm sure uh many here remember
clearly and remember abel archer perhaps
hopefully talk afterwards clearly um but
it wasn't just private fear it was very
public fear um this is uh an america one
item i chose to symbolize the year of
1983
and this was a very realistic
movie about nuclear war that aired on
national television
ronald reagan actually watched this days
before able archer 83 he had seen an
advanced screening
in his diary he wrote that it was very
well done and left me feeling greatly
depressed
and i've spoken with reagan watchers and
they say that it's probably uh the only
or one of the few i don't i didn't find
i could not find any more of him writing
more of depression um great fear
so it may have primed him
he also
watched a movie that's a little bit more
uplifting than this matthew broderick's
war games
and greatly enjoyed that one as well
while we're talking about movies there's
another one from 1983 that most people
or a lot of people haven't heard of
called threads which was from the uk and
that was actually based on a
parliamentary i believe inquiry british
about what exactly would happen during
after a nuclear war
in essentially five generations lost um
and that one was even bleaker than this
this fear of nuclear war was widespread
in the united states and the soviet
union as we'll talk about
it also was manifestation manifested in
a protest movement that worked well and
largely achieved its objectives the
nuclear freeze movement
which also
had a large effect on president reagan
and here's
the president speaking to the
evangelical association in
orlando
so the president's
rhetoric also
contributed to the nuclear danger in
june of 1982 he addressed the british
parliament and said that he would put
the soviet union the ash heap of history
he gave this well-known speech
in orlando in march of 1983 although it
was not cleared by the state department
or anyone outside of the white house and
was focused on domestic policy
it had a huge impact on foreign policy
he
called the soviets
the evil empire and deemed them the
focus of evil in the modern world which
if you look on the writings from the
other side had
great effect on soviet union
geopolitically and strategically they
did not get that as some have claimed it
was firing up the base um
i think the best
description of this that uh again my
colleague and director tom bland has
written about is called the paradox of
ronald reagan and one of the best to
describe it was
anatolia de brennan the ambassador to
five u.s presidents
as de brennan masterfully explained the
paradox of ronald reagan was that the
president saw nothing contradictory and
publicly and i think sincerely attacking
the soviet union as the evil empire and
describing his leadership in rather
uncomplementary terms while in the next
moment writing personal letters in his
own hand to the general secretary of the
soviet communist party very privately
expressing his desire for a non-nuclear
world better soviet american relations
and a summit meeting with the world's
chief communist and atheist
reagan's vision of nuclear apocalypse
and his deeply rooted but almost hidden
conviction that nuclear weapons should
ultimately be abolished would ultimately
prove more powerful than his visceral
anti-communism
though not i argue though not until
after the 1983 war scare had showed him
a break
two other brief examples of this paradox
of ronald reagan
the first
was uh
his military build-up uh he
uh
while quipping that he had wanted to get
a soviet leader in the room but they
kept dying on him it may be true but on
the other hand his actions militarily
said the opposite
the soviets were very startled by his
rhetoric and the deeds behind it and the
second i want to quickly mention uh is
the use of psychological
operations um
or psyops
and these also had a
great effect great importance for abel
archer 83. psychological operations um
and uh
i won't go into too much detail but
since reagan assumed the presidency he
started secretly confronting the soviets
as well these including included um
conducting bombing raids on soviet
territory soviets excuse me conducting
simulated bombing raves raids on
territory the soviets claimed as theirs
there's a great uh declassified demarch
from the soviet union about that
sneaking battleships into soviet air
waters
flying bombers at the soviet union and
switching off at the last second to test
where their uh radars were strong and
where they're weak
and i think david hoffman's recent
excellent book the billion dollar spy
showed that another part of this and the
reliance on human intelligence was that
the soviet's radars were weak everywhere
that they could not detect or possibly
protect their borders from american
incursions including nuclear strikes
but
while the president was hoping for the
abolition of nuclear weapons and
sometimes publicly wanting to work with
the soviets and very sometimes very
privately
begging the soviets to change the world
he was also increasing the military
publicly calling
them the evil empire and secretly having
secret military actions against the
soviet union
the fear was not just in america it was
in the soviet union too
one very interesting declassified memo
from the reagan presidential library
from u.s soviet advisor jack matlock to
national security advisor robert
mcfarlane
written in december 18 1983 but
describing the six months previous
said that for for the past six months
there was a fear of war that seemed to
affect the elite as well as the man on
the street on the soviet union
according to a well-respected source
a growing paranoia among soviet
officials
and that they were literally obsessed by
fear of war
and that
irrational irrationality and
unpredictability
of the soviet officials not seen since
30 years previously which was the reign
of stalin world just after world war ii
um
the danger of the fear of war and fear
of preemption can actually be seen in a
conversation between then general
secretary year yuri and dropoff and one
of the few meetings
between a u.s envoy avril harriman
who had previously negotiated with
stalin and was a democrat but was
unofficially sent by the reagan
administration he says that he was a
private citizen but the documents show
he traveled with the state department
translator and was pre-briefed and
debriefed by the state department but
during his conversation with andropov in
august 1983 um
harriman said uh and drop of stridently
risked of the risk of nuclear war
through through miscalculation four
times um and warned that quote they were
moving towards the dangerous red line of
nuclear war
then ahmed amid these pledges of
destruction of the evil empire the
danger of launch on warning
the quiet danger of operation rion um
and the fear of war affecting the elite
as well as the man on the street
k a l double 007 occurred the soviet
union shot down a u.s civilian airliner
that had errantly strayed into soviet
airspace
this ended any hope of improved
relations which would which was dim
and ratcheted up the fear of war the
tensions even further
here's what reagan wrote about the kl
shootdown
and his memoirs
if as some people speculated the soviet
pilot simply mistook the airliner for a
military plane what kind of imagination
did it
take to think of a soviet military man
with his finger close to a nuclear push
buck and making an even more tragic
mistake
and
as some of you guys probably know this
mistakes like this happen multiple times
throughout the cold war which we can
talk about during the questions but i
won't go into now because um
as a mistake by pushing the button is a
bit different than war through
miscalculation
so
a month after kal
able archer 83 began
um
so
again able archer 83 was a five-day nato
exercise
conducted at the end of autumn 4 jd 3.
now
some of you guys
it's a little hard to see but have any
of you guys watched the recent
television show deutschland 83
yeah uh it's a good show and it's about
able archer 83 it's a german show
and they contacted me and i helped them
with get some of the historical facts
straight but a very cool easter egg is
that each of the episodes of this cereal
come from an operation from autumn4j83
so there's northern wedding
you can see uh summer jump uh
display determination others and
that's a cool easter egg that i'd like
to share with you but
to understand able archer 83 is very key
to understand what exactly it was
each year there was an
annual able archer exercise and there
was an annual autumn forge exercise it
was how nato
prepared for war against the soviet
union autumn forge was large as you can
see it had about a dozen exercise under
it preparing troops
in lots of places
about twenty thousand troops including
some sixteen thousand american troops
that flew over
and this was practicing conventional war
and went on for months
abel archer 83 was the last final
exercise of this essentially practicing
the
shift from conventional war to nuclear
war
and how to fight it um and this is
important to understand because there
are previously there have been some
histories that cited uh soviet generals
saying i've never heard of abel archer
83
showing that there is no danger but in
the same interviews the general said
autumn forge that was always the most
dangerous
so
able archer came at the end of autumn
forge 83. so because it was so hard to
get this declassified i'd like to share
with you
what it practiced how did nuclear war
look in 1983
so here's the back story
there's a sudden change in leadership in
the kremlin a new unstable leader takes
over
then the fledgling leadership begins
fighting proxy wars in the u.s
against by providing political and
military support to rebels in iran syria
south yemen eventually months later this
conflict spreads from the middle east to
europe
and due to this failing economy the
soviet union was unable to continue
providing support to his satellites
but while the eastern european economic
situation worsened
the military preparedness improved
frequent field exercises were conducted
equipment was stockpiled factories
produced material around the clock then
in this back story in august 1983
yugoslavia shifted toward this west
request requesting economic and military
assistance from several nato countries
fearing other eastern european states
would join the shift to the west the
warsaw pact invaded yugoslavia
then the ground were broadened soviet
forces invaded finland october 31st the
next day norway
the next day
they attacked germany
by november 4th soviet and warsaw per
forces had invaded west germany
bomb this entire eastern border
but because nato
nato forces provided strong resistance
the soviets began launching chemical
attacks
nato responded in kind
that's the back story
now this is the part that
american and european
nuclear officers on the ground in europe
began practicing when
conventional and chemical war turns
nuclear
unable to repel the soviet's ground
advance nato attempted to send a message
to the warsaw pact via nuclear signaling
the destruction of one city in the hope
of averting total nuclear war i talked
to the ambassador to nato and he said
that in the scenarios this city was
usually kiev and the soviets usually
responded with boston
um
on the morning of november 8th nato
requested permission for
quote initial limited use of nuclear
weapons against pre-selected fixed
targets signaling
the western capitals granted nato
permission to destroy um in eastern
european city with a nuclear attack
but blues the west's use of nuclear
weapons did not stop orange's aggression
as a result the next day the leader of
nato
requested follow-on use of nuclear
weapons washington and the other
capitals approved this request and on
november 11th nuclear war had broken out
that was able archer 83.
here's president reagan with uh olive
gordievsky
of course the great one irony was that
while nato was practicing a long slow
drawn-out transition from conventional
to nuclear war the soviets were most
fearful of a bolt from the blue
and as such
were misreading indicators
in able archer 83 did indeed
have many special wrinkles that other ex
previous able archer exercises did not
that could have and would have been
misreported as
by rihanna indicators to the west um and
here i want to take a minute to talk
about ola gordaevsky
president reagan actually met with him
and actually wrote about him twice in
his journal both times
inquiring about his well-being
after
providing information to the british
which reached the u.s
in london um he was pr in all likelihood
betrayed by uh aldrich ames and
eventually was recalled to moscow
probably to be debriefed and executed
and he wrote a good book about this
gordievsky
but he was able ultimately to escape
across the finished border in the in the
trunk of a car um and eventually made it
and met with reagan and did a large tour
throughout the u.s and he's he's still
alive
he was also the first person that
sounded the alarm during able archer 83.
um
so
here are some wrinkles of able arthritis
iii that could have been picked up
during rion
testing of new
communication methods for nuclear
release i spoke with nato officers in
the field that said that they had just
been trained on new encryption
techniques to launch these new missiles
um
during able archer uh and that could
have been would have been reported by
rhiann
new nuclear release procedures including
practicing launching griffin and
pershing two missiles the fact that some
u.s aircraft practiced nuclear handing
procedures including taxing out of
hangars carrying realistic dummy
warheads
the 170 flight radio silent airlift of
16 000 soldiers
to our autumn 4 jg3 of which able archer
was the final component these this would
have been reported um during able archer
83 the shifting of command from
permanent war headquarters and mons to a
field headquarter simulating the
destruction um this was an indicator
that agents were tasked to look for a
report and including to one document
declassified by the u.s air force the
quote sensitive political issue of quote
slips of the tongue in which b-2
sorties were mistakenly referred to as
nuclear strikes over open radio which
actually in the u.s side
climbed the ladder as a reporting of of
danger even
without knowing of rion
these wrinkles according to olive
gordievsky
caused both the kgb and gru to send
flash telegrams to residencies in
western europe on november 8th when able
archer the nuclear phase began or 9th he
doesn't recall which reporting quote an
alert on u.s bases according to
gordievsky the flash telegrams clearly
implied that one of several possible
explanations for the alert was the
countdown to nuclear first strike had
actually begun
so
for years we only had this gordievsky
account
that may have been
some called it the echo chamber of
evidence but just last year ago
here people at the national archives
finally broke through the log jam and
declassified a key other
another key retrospective account
and this is probably
the most comprehensive it's all source
as you can see it has i think seven code
words on the top most of the stuff
leaked by snowden only had three
and it was an all-source review and
that's where much of the wrinkles i just
described come from there's also been
some declassification by british
intelligence
describing what they saw but essentially
what we now know through
declassification
is that this is what the soviet reaction
was in addition to the memo gordiewski
said
they were quote unparalleled in scale
and included transporting nuclear
weapons from storage sites to delivery
units by helicopter suspension of all
flight operations from november 4th to
10th probably to have available as many
aircraft as possible for combat
initiated unprecedented technical
collection against able arts ready 3
including over 36 overflights
significantly more than previous
exercises
soviet air units in east germany and
poland went on alert
and heightened readiness in what was
declared to be a threat of possible
aggression against the ussr and warsaw
pact countries
nuclear weapons were transparent from
storage sites to delivery vehicles via
helicopter and as the cia director casey
wrote to reagan in 1984
the behavior of the armed forces is
perhaps the most disturbing from the
operational deployment of submarines to
the termination of harvest support to
the delayed troop rotation there's a
central theme of not being strategically
vulnerable even if it means taking some
risks
the military behaviors we have observed
involve high military costs adding
thereby a dimension of genuineness to
the soviet expressions of concern that
is not often reflected in intelligence
issuances
and beyond that there have been a series
of interviews with
soviet generals and members of the
general staff saying that soviet nuclear
forces in fact did go on alert their
enabler 83 and reports that orga or
garcov monitored the situation from a
bunker outside of moscow
and
right after you read some of those in
there there's about a good page and a
half that remains blacked out redacted
so possibly probably even more
this is funny and maybe we'll get it to
questions but i want to wrap up this is
an example of declassification not as
good as is what is usually provided by
the national archives
during my research i did a foia request
a freedom of information act request to
the national security agency for
documents about able archer and they
said we have 83 documents
and we will give you one of them and the
one they gave me was this one
a printout of a wikipedia article that
had been processed and declassified and
the real the worst punch in the gut was
i spent a lot of time being the actual
guy that edited the wikipedia article
um but the good news is that was early
um and i got so upset and angry by this
that i was even more determined to file
the foias and file the mdrs and work my
way all the way up to icecap which we
can talk about later which ultimately
got this document released the key
document
so it was a blessing in disguise
all right so uh
wrapping up and then we can talk about
other things in the discussion um
the danger of able archer 83 according
to all the information we have now ended
when a young air force officer
in charge of able archery 83 minimized
the risk by doing nothing in the face of
evidence that part of the soviet armed
forces were moving to an unusual level
of alert that officer was limited per
roots on the left
perutz's action to do nothing is
described
not glowingly as fortuitous if
ill-informed
these officers acted correctly out of
instinct not informed guidance for in
the years leading up to able archer they
receive no guidance as the possibility
significance of the apparent change in
soviet military and political thinking
so i want to quickly
walk through what the u.s intelligence
committee learned and that debate that
now what has become onto the scholarly
committee community and the public
so the first to report able archer 83
was the british there were dia reports
at the time but they missed it they said
that there was increased soviet
surveillance but did not get the other
stuff
the key report is a british report
entitled soviet union concern about a
surprise nato attack
which combined gordeevsky's reporting
with after the fact
satellite intelligence and human
intelligence and
according to sources i spoke with was
written by a man named harry burke
unfortunately this key uh first report
of the danger remains classified i did a
long fight through the british system
and lost so in this case uh the american
system is better
but this information did make it to the
u.s
by
may of 1984 the cia used this
intelligence on a report entitled
implications of recent soviet military
political activities but they concluded
that there was no danger of nuclear war
through miscalculation the opposite of
what the british concluded um there's
even a
after the british report margaret
thatcher even instructed her cabinet her
intelligence ministers rather to
urgently consider quote how to approach
the americans
and ameliorate the risk of war through
nuclear decl
miscalculation and this emissary was
essentially brushed off by the state
department
and then this may 1984 report
downplaying the dangers was written
but
in june a month later
director casey wrote the memo i quoted
for saying that there was indeed danger
the next day people from the dia wrote a
memo to him saying don't tell the
president that retract it
and maybe this
nuclear danger would have remained a
blip if it had not been for general
pirates again
after his service in europe he joined
the dia eventually becoming becoming the
director of the defense intelligence
agency
intelligence agency when he retired
in 1989 he wrote one final
schwann song a memo that the dia
still has not declassified
describing what happened to him during
abel archer 83 the danger and
his anger and concern that this danger
of nuclear war through miscalculation
had been hidden and not analyzed
properly he sent it to the central
intelligence agency where it was buried
and
received almost no response he also sent
it to the president's board of foreign
intelligence the president's foreign
intelligence advisory board
which was a board that independently
advised the president they took up the
issue
nina stewart pictured there wrote the
report
interviewed over
a hundred participants during abel
archer 83 as you saw in the
classification markings had essentially
all access
and wrote what i think is the
is close to the definitive review of the
danger
eventually the existence was leaked to a
historian don oberdorfer and eventually
other historians including myself
followed the footnotes fought and filed
mdrs for this document
took about 12 years because the bush
presidential library under nara great
people there but they don't have the
authority to declassify they had to get
permission from 12 agencies
one of these agencies which wouldn't
even say who it was it was the cia
didn't do any action on it it was stuck
there
thank goodness there's one last body at
the national
archives called icecap the interagency
security classification appeals panel
which is
set up through executive order it still
stands
and states that when the agency can't
declassify something or takes too long a
panel of experts
from other agencies here at nara can
review the document and
release what no longer has national
which no longer would harm national
security they did and the public now
knows
thank goodness
all right finally um
three uh points in my conclusion
i think uh the first
is the power of leadership
president reagan ultimately
understood that a world on hair trigger
is unacceptable and continued to winding
down the cold war
upon learning of the danger of able
archer 83 reagan quote expressed
surprise and quote described the events
as really scary
he also learned from the danger of able
archer 83 in the war scare in his memoir
he answered the question that he asked
in that
in that note card that we showed earlier
um he wrote in his diary just after able
archer 83 and then changed it a bit in
his memoirs later that three years quote
three years had taught me something
surprising about the russians many
people at the top of the soviet
hierarchy were genuinely afraid of
america and americans
perhaps this shouldn't have surprised me
but it did
i think many of us in my administration
took it for granted that russians like
ourselves considered it unthinkable that
the united states would launch a first
strike against them but the more
experience i had with soviet leaders and
other heads of state who knew them the
more i been began to realize that many
soviet officials feared us not only as
adversaries but as potential aggressors
who might hurl nuclear weapons at them
in a first strike
the president
then in tandem with gorbachev the soviet
leader he could do business with
eliminated an entire class of
intermediate range missiles including
the persians 2's griffins and ss-20s
next the two negotiated on the strategic
arms
limitation reduction treaty start signed
by gorbachev and h w bush which reduced
the number of warheads in icmbms
to 6000 and 1000 respectively
the mutual trust generated by these
nuclear reductions was key to helping
the two leaders eventually attained the
peaceful end of the cold war the 1983
war scare served as a fulcrum that
pivoted u.s soviet relations from the
worst days of the cold war to their best
cooperation since world war ii
the second lesson i think is the lesson
that the cold war was a dangerous era
that we're lucky to have survived and
was not the sum of written along peace
the study of the previously secret
history of the 1983 war scare forces the
reevaluation of one of the core claims
of cold war historiography that the cold
war
was slowly wound down after the cuban
missile crisis
actually the danger of nuclear
confrontation remained constant and at
times including during able archer 83
escalated
the fact that an unacceptably high risk
of nuclear war continued to exist during
abel archer 83 21 years after the cuban
missile crisis undermines the theory of
nuclear deterrence and the idea that
because world war iii was avoided the
cold war was actually the long piece
as both sides continue to increase the
lethality of nuclear weapons their own
vulnerability increased
despite the protestations and advocates
of so-called nuclear learning and
treatises explaining how nuclear game
theories ameliorated the risk of actual
war both superpowers became more unsafe
as the cold war progressed
while the united states and soviet union
maintained relative nuclear parity each
lacked nuclear security the explanation
to this nuclear paradox is simple
theories don't shape the course of human
events people do
and finally
believe able archer 83 has lessons for
today
the best way
to ensure that the danger of nuclear war
continues to decrease is to not hide it
and dropoff and reagan relied upon
classified information unavailable to
the public to realize the untenable
nature of the nuclear arms race in the
early 1980s it is difficult to justify
the initial concealment of how
potentially lethal able archer 83 was
much less now 30 years after the fact 33
years
finally after many long freedom of
information act battles fought by the
national security archives and documents
declassified by people in this room
most but not all of the us documents on
it on the warsaw have been declassified
and other countries are trickling out to
the public
the continued study of the 1983 war
scare will help to avert current and
future nuclear standoffs reduce the
probability of nuclear war through
miscalculation and help battle against
dangerous ideas held by some keepers of
the keys
across the mall from us
the soviet ss20s and american persons
twos and griffins have been removed and
retired the cold war has ended the
soviet union no longer exists
30 years later a fuller picture of the
dangers of able archer 83 has finally
emerged and the lesson is soberingly
clear throughout the cold war as reagan
wrote
one misstep one misstep could trigger a
great war
we cannot return
thank you
[Applause]
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
anyone has please ask at the microphones
thank you very much for the presentation
as you described as far as maybe
expanding on that
the air force officer who did nothing
there was a russian i don't know if he
was an officer that saw satellite data
that showed uh five missiles coming his
way there were clouds that reflected the
sun i'm curious from that incident as
well as others that historically have
happened
what procedures obviously getting ready
rid of the the nuclear weapons is a good
step but the red phone aspect that
occurred between the hires up that you
said
folks that hold the keys what
speeders might have changed from that
incidence with table archer 83.
sure
so first to mention on general petrov
who
essentially there was
miss working soviet satellites again
that sent
information that a nuclear warhead was
coming his way and he too uh did nothing
he actually told his
superiors that it was a false alarm that
according to the reporting by david
hoffman he broke procedures and said
trust me it's nothing i know my gut says
that it's they wouldn't launch one
missile and i know the satellite doesn't
work um
there are there is another uh in a great
document of a soviet document of yuri
and drop of he was speaking he said we
could be annihilated by an american
drunk pushing the missile so the soviets
too were scared or a narcotic addict
he's it was his actual quote of someone
in the u.s military doing that there's a
story that most people many people know
of um
brzezinski later getting a call that 4
000 icbms were on the way
and he
was calm for one minute and then he got
another call saying don't worry it was
someone had just put in the training
tape um so these happen over and over
and over again um the only real solution
that i'm aware of the the best solution
is the reduction of nuclear weapons
taking weapons off hair trigger
posturing which they still are
there the
nuclear telephone so called the red line
that we now have actually stalled during
the reagan administration and was
potentially or greatly expanded after so
that's one safe measure
but the greatest absent of
having fewer nuclear weapons is having
them off-hair trigger alert
thanks
um thank you for this uh quite
interesting um
presentation you know i'm not from
america i'm from the caribbean you know
and uh
you know we had the cuban missile crisis
obviously and
i was very very small
and i
do remember sitting with my parents
listening to although they claim that i
made it up that i have a good
imagination i made it up absolutely not
this is what happened
i was a very smart kid i mean
extraordinary smart and i remember them
sitting on the porch
listening to the soviet ships coming
closer and closer to the uh
to the quarantine right
and the ships
at a certain moment stopping
and i'm trying i'm a kid obviously i'm
trying to figure out what is this
what can this i mean how to make sense
of this and the only thing i could do
is uh think it's some type of hellish
activity but be that as amazed so i do
have experience with it again i grew up
in the netherlands so i was part of the
demonstrations against the new york
american but a few questions because
what you do here i think is quite
important especially with more and more
countries coming online that become more
and more powerful right
china
india
the nuclear weapon uh the nuclear
problems between
potential problems between india and
pakistan right what level of control do
these people have over the thing what
level of weather systems they have back
and forth to be able to do this
so um do you know anything about that is
has there been any talk about that
what to do about this uh this issue and
also i think what helped tremendously
with
stopping really a nuclear war from
happening between the the soviet union
and the united states is that from the
very beginning
think about oppenheimer's first word
right i've become dead
both and and um
the the
dissident i forgot his name um
sakura right who wanted who when he saw
this thing exploded like no this is this
is just in this this is nonsense we
cannot do this this cannot be done
but think about it if
it was a competition between
the united states and for example china
where for example mouse and zoom thought
it was kind of a joke we have enough of
people a few hundred million is no
problem to us right
just less people but we have hundreds of
millions more
you know the issue is that if both
intellectual classes and technic classes
and military classes don't read this
thing the same way right and what you
have been talking about is what
political scientists call a security
dilemma right the security dilemma is a
horrific
dangerous thing when when you have
nuclear weapons so how do you see all of
these things playing out and i totally
agree with you that we need a new
movement popular movement across the
world to really put an end to these
nuclear weapons and now we have a new
guy coming in who claimed he might be
going towards nuclear more nuclear
weapons etc so how do you see this thing
playing out in your future and the last
question because you talk about the
issue of um
getting documents right we've known that
over the last few years in different
presidents presences they have been
attempt now to try to hide more
documents how do you see that playing
out going forward thank you
sure
so
i would say the the big most difficult
answer i think is that the truest risk
of nuclear war is not through two
leaders
pushing the button it's war through
miscalculation or war through
non-proliferation or war from
events spiraling spiraling out of
control i think we saw how that could
have happened during abel archer we know
that could have happened during the
cuban missile crisis so the
straightforward
use of nuclear weapons as they are
intended is not the greatest risk
how to combat that
well uh i think uh
my small way is through writing history
of nuclear history and trying to get the
secrets out so the public knows this
danger more fully or can rely on the
historical documents instead of memoirs
or the echo chamber as as i said earlier
and i'll say i would
i love working with the nuclear history
project
international history and
non-proliferation project at the wilson
center and my work the national security
archive so as a historian that's my way
of fighting is showing the danger and
getting the stories out and getting
people that had second thoughts in these
governments and said so secretly to make
that public
the last question about how to make sure
we have access to documents going
forward it's going to be a challenge but
historians and people that love foia
it's always a challenge our fighters
we know how to fight the department of
justice to get the documents out we know
how to get
right good mdr requests we know that
people that work in the archives are
driven by getting the documents uh
documents out as well so i'm optimistic
that our declassified history will keep
flowing
[Applause]
uh
you